okay let's talk about Donald Trump and
Ivanka Trump Donald Trump has a very
long history of really strange sexual
comments related to his own daughter
Ivanka and it seems to be getting worse
and I told you yesterday
that porn star stormy Daniels claimed
that she had a year-long affair with
Trump while he was married and that she
was either offered or given a hundred
and thirty thousand dollars in hush
money to never talk about the affair now
she is all of a sudden denying that she
ever had a relationship with Trump she's
saying no no we had a series of sexual
encounters and that's it but she also
has said that during the time the affair
was taking place Trump told her that she
reminds him of his own daughter Ivanka
Trump Daniel said quote he told me once
that I was someone to be reckoned with
beautiful and smart just like his
daughter isn't that lovely that's just
what every woman wants to hear during a
sexual affair with a much older man that
she reminds the guy of his daughter now
if this were a completely unique and
disconnected statement from Trump's past
we might easily brush it off and not
even mention it but like with most of
what we hear about Trump its
corroborating what we already know about
him years ago in 2015 I did a video that
went viral about Donald Trump's
obsession with his daughter's body and
how he would have sex with her if they
weren't related that video now has
nearly three million views on YouTube
and one of the clips in that video was
the following very very creepy video all
right I I'm afraid to ask this question
but what would you do playboy put in
blanca on the cover of the magazine is
she had nas is gonna be an interesting
answer it would be really disappointing
not really it would depend on what was
inside the magazine now if she posed it
would be fine but if they put a picture
on it depends on what goes inside the
night
this girl's great there'll be new to
nude photos you do a super okay you
wouldn't have an issue with it then if
they were using her - I don't think
Ivanka would do that inside the magazine
although she does have a very nice
figure I've said that if Ivanka weren't
my daughter perhaps I'd be dating her
absolutely the first thing Trump sees
when he looks at Ivanka is someone that
he would be having sex with were it not
for the fact that it's his daughter
and then here's audio from the Howard
Stern Show also from years ago
you know who's one of the great beauties
of the world according to everybody and
I helped create her Ivanka Ivanka yeah
she's six feet tall she's got the best
body here she's hot she made a lot of
money as a model a tremendous amount and
then she went cold turkey and gave it
all up because she had to go to college
because I wanted her to go to college
she goes to the best college Jordan she
goes to Wharton she's got straight A's
Wharton just absolutely stunning and
then more recently out of everyone in
the Oval Office during a press
conference with Irish press he calls
over this one reporter who looks exactly
like Ivanka and starts hitting on her
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah and then of course numerous quotes
I'll just show you one this is from a
Rolling Stone article about Trump from
September of 2015
talking about his daughter saying quote
yeah she's really something and what a
beauty that one if I weren't a happily
married and you know her father are we
now ready to say that this is a little
bit weird and also just lots of weird
pictures of them and what look more like
romantic situations not father/daughter
situations very very weird stuff and
these pictures are downright creepy
what will the defense be from the right
Trump is a real feminist he admits he
finds even his own daughter attractive
enough to have sex with her I don't know
is this the biblically mandated thing a
real Christian where marriage is
something between a man and a few wives
interspersed with Affairs with porn
stars and sexual harassment of more than
a dozen women I don't know I just think
he's that much of a narcissist that he's
attracted to the female version of
himself right his offspring that's
interest but also I feel a little bit
bad for Tiffany too it doesn't seem like
she gets the same attention she's
getting almost no attention and from
what I know she's almost like kind of
estranged from Trump I don't know to
what degree that's true but and I don't
think that would be a shock to anybody I
actually don't care about any of this
other than the creepy daughter stuff
beyond the fact that there's just this
incredible hypocrisy from Trump and his
supposedly evangelical base about how
this is the godly guy and he's do
everything is just so great but he's got
a long track record of infidelity
relationships with porn stars which
again I have no problem with but by
their standards it's a problem and a
really weird penchant for for making
strange comments about his own daughter
yeah how does that evangelical base
justify that they attacked John F
Kennedy they attacked Bill Clinton for
having affairs allegedly in one case uh
and then Trump just gets a pass for some
reason you know why because eighteen
months ago he decided after an entire
life of being pro-choice that he's
against abortion so hey he's a great guy
and they're gonna vote for him because
he's godly the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership